die stimmung auf mallorca ist super
klammern merkt angespannt wir müssen
überall den mundschutz tragen wir müssen
überall unsere hände desinfizieren aber
es ist für uns hier auf mallorca nicht
so schlimm wie man es hört von überall
also wir bekommen es hier nicht so böse
mit wie es eigentlich sein soll besteht
aber was bedeutet denn das jetzt diese
reisewarnung die ihr wahrscheinlich auch
noch kommt was bedeutet das jetzt für
die insel urlauber können natürlich
jetzt abreißen wenn sie eine
pauschalreise gebucht haben ja schade
für die inseln ist es eine wunderschöne
insel wir haben uns wirklich in mallorca
verliebt und es tut ein wäre man sieht
man da ist am strand lang und jedes
zweite hotel ist geschlossen die
urlauber fahren nach hause
wahrscheinlich werden viele existenzen
kaputt gehen viele leute werden ihren
job verlieren und das tut einem schon
irgendwie weh wenn man dass sie wie
geht's euch dabei nach uns geht es
möglich hier sehr gut an sich aber man
merkt dass halt überall jeder läuft hier
mit einer maske rum
in den hotels hat jeder permanent eine
maske manchmal vergisst man das weil in
deutschland ist es ja ein bisschen
anders aber da kommt sofort jemand die
uns sagt du musst sofort deine maske
aufsetzen und dann hast du sie wieder
drauf ja die sind mega strecken was die
masten angela und bleibt er jetzt vor
ort
wir werden auf jeden fall vor ort aber
wir reisen ja sowieso schon morgen
ziemlich gut
und natürlich hat man mulmiges gefühl
wir wissen nicht kommen wir nach hause
oder haben wir uns doch irgendwie
irgendwo auf angesteckt oder wird der
test positiv sein müsste mir in
quarantäne man weiß es ja nicht es gibt
ja viele die bekommen den virus ohne
dass sie es merken
vielleicht sind wir auch so dass die
patienten wir wissen es noch nicht aber
sie beten und hoffen dass wir gesund
geblieben sind und der urlaub hier hat
uns riesenspaß gemacht daran konnte uns
auch der virus nicht ändern und die
maske auch nicht